it is April 12 2023 and you are watching
the code report angular is and always
will be the greatest framework to ever
grace the JavaScript landscape but it
can't seem to get no respect back in
2010 angularjs was the first framework
to popularize the idea of declarative
components but react gets all the
respect in 2014 when viewjs came out it
was basically just angular light when
angular 2 embraced typescript back in
2016. everybody laughed at it and said
typescript was for microsofty losers but
angular gets no respect for being light
years ahead of its time everybody loves
spelled stores but guess he was doing
reactive patterns like that years before
with rxjs a framework called angular
that gets no respect oh that's the story
of my life no respect people on the
internet love to hate it but angular is
still extremely popular with
professional developers and Enterprise
second only to react over the last five
years its focus has been on reliability
and stability and as a result it stopped
pumping out game-changing features but
in 2023 many people are forecasting an
angular Renaissance because the
framework is in the process of
introducing the biggest change it's seen
in years with a new feature called
signals the framework was sick and tired
of getting no respect so now it's
turning the tables and implementing a
feature inspired by Frameworks like
preact solid.js and view before we get
into it though I want to explain
something important the JavaScript
framework Wars are largely an illusion
although they do compete for the mine
share of developers that creators and
maintainers all go to the same
conferences hang out together and work
together like mishko the creator of
angular is now working on the quick
framework which itself uses signals when
you see people bashing a free and open
source framework it's usually just the
result of tribalism and paradoxically
we're more tribal than ever thanks to
the social media that connects us all
but the reality is that all these
Frameworks collaborate to make web
development better for all of us and for
that they all deserve our respect the
only exception is react which is a
adhesive and I hope where the doctor's
like until it has to use itself as a but
what are angular signals exactly a
signal is a new reactive primitive or
data structure that can handle values
that change over time like the state of
your application currently angular uses
a library called zonejs to handle State
changes in your application it works in
a kind of magical way to track various
browser events then automatically check
the component tree when a change might
have happened it's nice because you
don't need hooks like set State and
react but it can lead to Performance
issues and also weird edge cases like
the dreaded expression changed after
it's been checked error but now with
signals change detection will be much
more precise and surgical that's a nice
benefit but angular is already tightly
integrated with rxjs which has things
like observables and behavior subjects
that on the surface look very similar to
signals they're both capable of handling
a stream of values that change over time
with an observable though you need to
call a subscribe method a signal on the
other hand you call directly like a
function that may seem trivial but it
dramatically simplifies the way things
are done in angular for example to
create computed values you kind of need
to be an rxjs wizard who understands
observables and behavior subjects and
then how to pipe in different operator
functions to map one value to another
this code can get extremely complex and
requires Hungarian notation with dollar
signs at the end just to keep things
straight signals on the other hand can
use this computed function to make the
code more concise and readable the same
is true for side effects which can be
executed with this effect function
signals can also be writable which means
you can change the value manually with
either set or update so overall this
provides a much more approachable API
for handling reactive data not much
different than solid or vue.js however
signals are still fully compatible with
rxjs for handling more complex streams
of data overall signals look awesome but
that's not the only cool thing about
modern angular one of its most hated
features was the NG module which you had
to learn about before you could even
build a damp component but now it
supports Standalone components to
eliminate this requirement in addition
there are projects like analog gaining
steam which is a nexjs like meta
framework with file system routing for
SSR so to end this video I'll leave you
with a question is angular a great
framework or the greatest framework of
all time this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one